you know when you were down there
everybody was looking down at you and
Nancy said what in the world is she
doing what is pumping through her body
what kind of DNA does she have whatever
she's drinking I wanted one what are you
wearing you look don't move all
what's your secret what is it just be
happy be happy in all things be content
in all things be content she told you
look black Black Panther wasn't just a
movie it was a moment it was a movement
and what does it mean that we are here
now and it's being acknowledged on the
Oscar stage because not long ago we
understood what was going on here
absolutely the turn of events but it was
excellent from top to bottom not be
ready could not be denied
you know I gotta tell you I think that
not you have got on the trend tonight
because I'm looking a Helen Mirren
behind you is wearing pink
facing musgraves to your right has got
on pink so all the big celeb scene get
you up jump spring you got to give us an
update on a black panther - nothing I
know nothing well I keep hearing that
you're about to start writing we breathe
again I'm in the writers room
no the writing is about to begin about
that really soon yeah are you excited
about it it's what a wonderful cat
excited so I hope it's I hope it I hope
you can see it within well not too long
don't bring it too quick because we have
a standard we have a standard to read
write celebrate in some way tonight and
he parties as we've seen as we have seen
he parties Kourtney you lost you're lost
in the Grammys but you lost to the
former president I was a blessing to be
there you know my first foray out in the
category reported books I'm ready to go
back in 600 babies that's not so physics
in the military what is bad now I do
want to know that the cast has talked
about the fact that you guys the first
superhero movie to be nominated for an
Oscar
it blows your mind you know but you
never say what's possible or impossible
you want to know what do your kids think
of their mom is in the greatest
superhero movie of all time how does
that click in I think they think is
pretty cool and I can see the little
pride in their little step and it also
you know as a mom dad you need all the
points you can be male you can get from
wherever so play this together or you
can draw one each and read the question
there are DJ's on the Oscar carpet what
song would really get the party started
why stop Bohemian Rhapsody and why well
for me what gets it started is shining
it's that kind of night all the lights
all the stars yeah it has an infectious
beat all that winning well that quarter
yours is based on the star is born what
do you most remember about starting out
of Hollywood
you know I remember Hunt for Red October
just came to my my and that was a was my
first big film and it was I wasn't just
in awe of everything specially Sean
Connery no more smoke he was he was he
was the it guy so an atom Jack Ryan
bridge a crime Oh John Jack go without a
wallet so we were we were all little
babies in the movie with John so I
remember always asking you know of
course it was you know the stars the
celebrities that you always you know saw
and I always wondered are they nice are
they nice and the meet a number of them
and a number of them were and it some of
them maybe not so but to meet those who
were nice and some gracious generous
with their spirit it was that's why
you're so nice okay that's why you're so
nice now that's why you're so nice now
both
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]